الضوء الاخضر الذي منحته واشنطن لاوكرانيا
ولاوروبا لتزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16
واستخدامها في القرن قابله رد روسي سريع
تمثل باستهداف مستودعات اسلحه وذخيره
ومعدات طائرات اوكرانيه في مطار دانيبرو
المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه قال ان
الضربه كانت دقيقه ونجحت في تحقيق الهدف
منها بعد ان تسببت في تدمير عدد من
المرافق بالمطار ومن بينها موقع تقني
لتجهيز الصواريخ المستشار الالماني
وصف تدريب الطيران الاوكرانيين على
مقاتلات اف 16 بانها اشاره الى بوتر
للتراجع عن اهدافه في اوكرانيا وقال في
تصريحاته لصحيفه ديفلت الالمانيه
لن يحقق هدفه في اوكرانيا من خلال مواصلته
الحرب وجعلها طويله الامد اوضح ان المانيا
لا تملك طائرات اف 16 لتزويد اوكرانيا بها
لذلك لا تناقش تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين
حاليا الا انها تقوم بتزويد كييف بالدفاع
الجوي والع ربات المدرعه والمدفعيه
الثقيله على حد قوله
اذا المقاتلات اف 16 صقور قد تقلب قواعد
اللعبه في سماء اوكرانيا وتقد مضجع روس
فاعطاء الرئيس الامريكي الضوء الاخضر
للحلفاء بتسليم طائرات اف 16
من تورط مباشر للنيتو في الصراع لكن كيف
وبماذا يختلف تسليح الغرب لاوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات رغم ارسله عشرات الحزمات
العسكريه قبلها سفير موسكو في واشنطن تضرع
بعدم وجود بنيه تحتيه لتشغيل مقاتلات اف
16 في اوكرانيا مرجحا فرضيه اقلاع
المقاتلات الامريكيه من قواعد الجويه
للنيتو كما لفت الى نقص العدد المطلوب من
الطيارين وافراد الصيانه ما يعني ان
متطوعين اجانب سيسيطرون في الجوف
اذا مقاتلات اف 16 او الصقور المقاتله
تشكل عامله ثقه لمواجهه الروس وهي
المقاتله الاكثر مبيعا واستخداما في
العالم قاتله خفيفه الوزن ذات محرك واحد
تتميز بسرعتها ومرونتها وقدرتها على
المناوره حيث يبلغ طولها 15 مترا وطول
جناحيها عشره امتار تقريبا تصميماتها
تغيرت منذ تصنيعها لاول مره في سبعينيات
القرن الماضي فهي الان متعدده المهام
قتاليه تقصف تكتيكيا قادره على الدفاع
الجوي كذلك يذكر ان السلاح الجوي
الاوكراني يعتمد حتى اللحظه على اعداد
صغيره من طائرات قديمه هذه الطائرات تعود
الى الحقبه السوفيتيه من طائرات ميج 29
وسخوي 27
واشنطن تقدم الضوء الاخضر لتسليم مقاتلات
اف 16 للجيش الاوكراني بعد تزايد الضغوط
عليها هل ستغير المقاتلات ميزان القوى
المقاتلات ستساهم في تعزيز المجال الجوي
الاوكراني وحمايه البنيه التحتيه وصد
الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه المقاتلات ترصد
اهدافها بدقه في جميع الظروف لها القدره
على استكشاف الطائرات المعاديه
واشنطن رفضت تقديم المقاتلات خوفا من
تسريب التكنولوجيا التي تعمل بها الى
موسكو ديميترو كوليبا وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه هناك حاجه لتطوير السلاح الجو
الاوكراني لصد الغارات الروسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات